[Music]
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
shoot that in the air it's on let them
know we're out here
that's how we do it here it's leftovers
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
I'm joined today by uh Yi son [ __ ] who
was recently banned from the internet
for expressing deeply anti-semitic uh no
I'm just no actually as a matter of fact
if I was saying anti-semitic things I'd
be totally fine on the Internet it's
that I was addressing the anti-semitic
commentary and criticizing it uh as uh
as as ironic as they may sound I was
actually talking about how like Nazis
don't really care about free speech and
they just lie and act like they care
about Free Speech but they love Banning
people and then they love Yeah like they
love utilizing whatever mechanism that's
against Free Speech they can like
there's no principles there anyway and
then I got banned like 10 minutes after
okay so tell me what happened
you were streaming Kanye's on his uh his
Nazi World Tour yeah yeah he's doing
competitive racism on like uh Gavin
mcginnis's show Gavin once famously put
a dildo in his butt to own the lives
leader of the proud boys creator of the
white supremacist domestic terrorist
group proud boys but like the kind of
the whack is Terrorism to be honest yeah
like they're super lame um well what
would make them cooler like uh I think
if they didn't have like an a ceremony
where they like kind of tickle you and
you have to name five cereal brands
that's a little y'all think I'm joking
but that's very real that's that's
literally uh Frosted Flakes uh uh Lucky
Charms like like life now five other
divorced yeah you know dads who are like
32 uh will beat you in like they'll jump
you in like the Bloods and Crips but
that's how that that's actually their
initiate I don't know about the
breakfast show but they they punch each
other and then yeah while you have to
name five conventional breakfasts right
yeah cereals I mean that's Gavin
mcginnis's like group of course gonna be
whack as [ __ ] they're like uh you know
they're they're proud misogynists uh who
want to defend the Western superiority
like Western surprise like favorite way
brands or something like that nah it's
just cereal because they're whack as
[ __ ] all right well um so so anyway
you're watching yay on Gavin mcnewson's
uh show academic news Gavin the the
Houston yeah
was his hot as gruesome Newsome okay
yeah
um anyway I was watching that and I was
criticizing it and then they found out
that I was watching it and like asthma
gold had watched it before me like to
completion
um earlier today fine looking man and he
had like even more viewers than I did
anyway yeah he is hot oh God raped me
off
um
and yeah they they heard about it and
they varied directly the CTO
like the chief technology officer or
whatever of sensor.tv personally copy
struck me and no one else on the
platform and now what I find interesting
again is they were streaming onto a
website called sensor TV do you find
that ironic no I mean it's just that is
exactly what it is it they just lie
they're they don't give a [ __ ] about
Free Speech yeah he so this guy was
banned on all platforms they made a
website called sensor.tv because they're
of course the only people who are
actually in favor of free speech
and went to and uh and uh dmca to your
stream so but actually you were
originally banned for 20 of 48 Hours
yeah but it got reduced it yeah okay
that's nice
yeah it was nice
um but I didn't even stream for that
duration I'm gonna be I'm Gonna Be Live
after this so yeah good welcome back
it's still a 48-hour one for me on my
end because I was playing valorant the
entire day
well that looks nice do you get a little
break or do you like it but when you're
getting banned a little bit you know
what I mean no no I hate it but you know
I had gotten on my valorant grind so I
was like [ __ ] it like I'm just gonna
keep it going what flavor we get them
here
black cherry that's what I [ __ ] with oh
no all right let's see hit that bro
Hassan asked for some uh G fuel to hit
him in the morning
that's [ __ ] up testing you bro okay
what's up yo [ __ ] do you feel Bro [ __ ]
you that the fact that that's even
invite my image
is too right no [ __ ] ninja that's that's
what I'm saying yo what's up ninja
what's up dude yo I got two words for
you man there you go those are the ones
that's just it's [ __ ] up that they
have this Market Supremacy that I just
say that because it's all about gamer
sup and that's why we're here is to
honor the great brand gamer the main
reason we do this show this is why I
wake up every day go to get and guys use
code H3 so that they don't get mad at me
Jesus Christ how is that as good right
actually surprisingly not bad the black
cherry is everything and [ __ ] G fuel
some of the some of the other ones I've
had were not as good oh you know not for
me I agree to be honest there's some
people have refined palettes you know I
I don't have one of them I do have a
refined palette and I can really parse
the flavors of the gamers up powder
yeah and I've come to the conclusion
that black cherry is everything
I don't know how the [ __ ] Kanye had this
thing on his face where like his his
eyes and his mouth were covered I think
it's like a design it's like a designer
thing he can see through it and breathe
fine it's like a nice fabric yeah that
that's like a heavy this sucks yeah yeah
you don't have to worry I don't know how
the IRA did this for so long like I
guess you know living under British
occupation you know forces you to learn
a lot forces you to tough it up yeah so
are you are you good at Valerian are we
making good good use of this time no I'm
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] of Valerie right I've
been playing one one agent I've been
playing rays and she's like kind of
Technical and kind of hard to play okay
um but I tried a new agent yesterday KO
I was playing all right with it I don't
know all right I'm just not good at it
it just sucks it makes me so mad well
you're old man yeah literally once
you're over like 26 you just start
sucking
I had multiplayer video games it's not
the same it's just not the same yourself
dude you aged out at 26. we'll juice him
bro did you see that what my problem is
I started playing on the PC again at
like 26 27 that was my issue yeah your
hand you're handicapped yeah bro find me
a professional
find me a professional Starcraft 2
player who's over the age of like 22.
they age out bro you need that elastic
brain
thank you okay who cares about video
game we're here to talk about the
decline
of our great nation and what do we do
about it
I want a streaming
so so uh
did you get yeah you know you're good at
streaming yeah for sure no I said I want
a streamy oh yeah you want to streamy
yeah no that's cool Ethan is not even
listening to me today he's just like
rushing he's like I need to talk about
the news goddamn yeah you want to stream
me well I was I don't yeah I mean it was
congratulations that's good yeah and I
saw you there yeah we hung out
I have a pic I have actually a short
clip of us meeting and and uh having a
good time at the stream is here we are
meeting that night wonderful oh my God
Ethan you made it dude that's crazy yeah
children like I really thought that you
would not make it to an event like this
we haven't chilled in a while bro I know
we host a podcast together left field
yeah we haven't chilled in a while wow
okay I gotta go bye Ethan all right man
yeah yeah I thought it was a little rude
how you cut me off there but it's okay
you were busy you're an award winner and
I get it you had places to be yeah uh we
haven't chilled in a while man
that's that was cool
I guess it means nothing to you this
podcast doesn't count huh well first of
all
why because I didn't go to Streamys we
got in this [ __ ]
this is the five time being nominated
for podcasts of the year who won over
uh call me call her dad call someone
Daddy
call Daddy she's hot daddy okay
but uh so what she deserves to beat us
I mean no listen I'm a part of the pot
I'm a part of the part of these three
families
oh you're lost more bro I get it call
her daddy don't start your car tomorrow
I heard you're disrespecting the H3
podcast Production Studio oh [ __ ] yeah
okay that's brother that's the joke
that's a joke it's too late bro the
quartering's already tweeted that no I
mean they're gonna say like he did it
the quartering's gonna clip that and be
like Hassan [ __ ] with like three s's
like making a joke about Ira style car
bombing the call or caller daddy podcast
are we allowed to actually so let me get
this straight uh he's gonna do Tate was
banned on YouTube but Hassan is allowed
to threaten people's lives yeah that
actually happened to me I'm taking this
off um yeah you take it off dude you
pissed off the funniest goobers with
your Christian tweet yes that's crazy
I actually didn't see that one coming I
gotta be honest I did that I did that
hair shake for all the ladies watching
uh the leftovers
leftovers chat it's Maybelline
yeah so did you well let's go back a
little bit so you got banned did you
hear the Gavin acknowledge it was there
anything or it's just whatever you move
on um well they like retweeted some
other [ __ ] like
weird
Nazi guy who's like we caught him like
we were the ones who let Gavin know that
he was watching the podcast
and then he copy strike them like that
was I assume that's how they speak Ethan
what does that free speech.tv later
tonight yeah you're gonna stop dissing
the Nazis all the time I think that's
right I think you need a that's I mean
that's basically what like twitch did
this is two for two now last year around
this time twitch capitulated to like
white supremacists and their coordinated
uh Mass uh uh you know Banning campaign
where they were crying about the word
cracker oh man and then this December is
not my month man August is August and
December two months of the year where I
just always get caught
in some controversy
and and now it's happening on Twitter
just for an example like I'm still
banned right I mean
and there's been this whole okay this is
not this
um there's been this whole
wait what oh here what do you mean H3
predictone this is what uh live and well
Productions Productions
this Andrew Tate is free from
his Twitter ban thankfully it's very
about that and of course I'm still
banned but that's okay
um [ __ ] yes podcaster Ethan Klein says
he will perform a mock execution of
Jesus on Christmas Day dedicated to Nick
Clinton you bet your ass I'm going to
bro
that's an insane thing no no shot yeah
yeah I don't know if you guys remember
the clue
so you could sit in your parents
basement and cry about him
yeah and I do it again give me the spear
them getting mad at this is pretty funny
it's funny for so many original nerds
dude good if Jesus was here on a cross
that's my job that's my job
you can't have your cake and eat it too
on one hand you the Jews were supposed
to kill Jesus right I mean I don't think
the Jews killed Jesus whatever I didn't
even I don't even you know what I mean
whatever I'm just talking about what's
in your [ __ ] psychosis for getting
mad at that is literally like saying
like I'm gonna recreate the big bang and
then people being like what you're gonna
destroy the whole universe or like uh
like a asteroid the asteroids that that
destroy the dinosaurs like whoa it's a
mess Extinction event he's saying it
it's like bro what yeah well Andrew
tweeted out the clip and he says what
will Christians do nothing cause he's
Muslim now he's ready to go Jihad on me
no he's just he's just uh he's a Muslim
man now so he's saying like you know
he's goading the Christians he's saying
like y'all don't take action like you
don't take matters into your arms no
he's he's pro-jihad he wants the Crusade
Jihad technically means struggle I'm not
gonna get further into it but there's a
there's a more complicated
no no no no like Jihad is like a
okay so what should I call it then no he
just he just he's a [ __ ] whatever
Andrew yeah I'm sure you want me talking
about jihads at a time like this yeah I
mean so the IRA would be what they did
was the Jihad technically but like not
because they were car bombing but
because they were fighting against an
occupying Force so you know Jihad can be
an honorable thing uh guys can we edit
the gamer Subs out of the terrorist pick
please thing you know what I mean yeah
hey at least put the G fuel with the
terrorist yeah I was gonna say it that's
cheap G fuels never but first of all I
mean these are the cool terrorists come
on these are the white the white Bears
well not only that but also they're like
anti-english so right okay Lizzy in a
box yeah
yeah so over this joke but am I wrong or
is he he's basically
he's saying like you'll do nothing like
your your Christians are his whole thing
is like he's a top G and uh the only G
is Allah and Muhammad is his Prophet
right um so I've been Muslim by the way
for two weeks yeah so now he's like you
know welcome welcome to the Brotherhood
uh Andrew
um brother Andrew so he uh
he's just like first of all he's a he's
a Westerner so like his understanding of
Islam is a revert is going to be like
very orientalized to begin with which is
ironic because this is one of those
things like these guys see like Islam as
like a non-cocked religion because it's
like
kind of uh the only religion that it has
out of the abrahamic ones is like
uh mostly practice in the Middle East
rather than in the western world and a
lot of the uh the most fundamentalist
right-wing conservative Muslims also see
Islam in these countries as a proximity
like a it's from Western liberal
capitalism you know what I mean they see
it as like either an emancipatory Force
like they do in Iran you know what I
mean that's why you have the Iranian
regime
um
or they they basically see it like
practicing it as like something that is
freeing them from Western liberal
capitalism which is soy and gay right
and cucked okay
um and while there are well there is
truth to that like Western liberal
capitalism is like very soy and very
cocked maybe dare I say gay not as a
pejorative
um gay
these guys
their understanding of their
understanding of Islam is monolithic and
and resembles like uh Sam Harris's way
of understanding it but he thinks that's
a positive yeah he loves that that's the
thing he's like yeah you know four wives
and beating all of them and also Sharia
and doing Jihad
at me and calls me bald and if somebody
jokes about our Prophet we kill them
yeah that's like that's kind of like you
know that's his that's a great analysis
of the situation like the way that
westerners imagine Islam as like some
um like as a monolith of ultra
conservative uh
uh yeah there sees that as he's like
that's what I like yeah exactly that's
why he's like no longer he doesn't want
to be a cucked guy he doesn't want to be
like a cucked religion follower so
that's why he found God uh in in you
know in the glory of Allah yes so
Christians uh will do nothing uh but uh
hopefully if you want to prove yourself
you can come harm me of course I mean
what I think he wants someone to hurt me
no what the [ __ ] Ethan if you get like
dude that's what this tweet says bro if
you get harmed over like the lamest like
oh my God this is this is not even like
your NRA moment you know what I mean
this is like the wackest thing that
anyone could ever get mad no but I think
what I learned looking through the
tweets which I'll open now is that I
tapped into the craziest [ __ ]
out there yeah no you pissed off like
you pissed off people who like are Ultra
Christian but also incredibly online
here is
um the quartering you can understand you
can bet even keemstar didn't even tweet
this one I think right it's so because
it's so [ __ ] stupid it's like getting
mad if you said like I'm gonna kill the
Easter Bunny yeah well the quartering
did tweet it out he said Ethan Klein is
at it again this is the clip that went
uh viral on Christian fascist uh Twitter
Ethan Klein said he's playing a mock
execution
for Jesus Christ for Christmas give me
the hammer and the spike I'm putting his
ass up there even Hassan seems
uncomfortable yeah that's my fave as
they always put these this weird thing
on you guys like uh the whole crew was
so uncomfortable yeah no I was so I was
so terrified
execute Jesus Christ bro yeah good if
Jesus he's been dead for like over 2 000
years guys don't worry
I just kind of knew that this is what
was going to happen and whatever I don't
regret it was funny that's why I was
like oh God it's [ __ ] the worst nerds
are gonna get mad at you Christ nerds so
here this is where it started and
actually apparently Nick Fuentes uh sent
it out in a sap group Jewish podcast or
even classes he will perform a mock
executioner Jesus on Christmas dedicated
to Nick Fuentes proving he ain't right
Star of David oh you know what's
interesting this means that yay likely
saw that clip
since they're homies they travel
everywhere together Kanye saw my [ __ ]
yeah you got your favorite content
creator notice you got a cc notice
what's up Kanye [ __ ] y'all [ __ ] dude bro
I I need to wait stop the second one is
is like it needs to be studied okay
this guy starts off saying Ethan Klein
is seriously mentally ill his name is
chalky milk Zoomer are you [ __ ]
kidding me you can't have a griper
account where you act like you're a 14
year old when you're like a divorced 45
year old dad and you talk to each other
like you have you know like some
debilitating mental illness caused by a
car accident or they do like baby
friend talk to baby talk like this is
the [ __ ] that do that
mentally ill friends
he needs to get back on his mids and
stop surrounding himself with these yes
men and neighbors I'm chalky milk Zuma
well you changed my diaper hey hey Joey
will you change my diaper I made a pee
pee again ah school was really hot today
wasn't it friends it's like bro you're
45 shut the [ __ ] up you're not allowed
this is the hero school this is this is
why your kids were were taken from you
bro this is why your wife
Zoomer dude that's crazy so that's one
here's another one Vatican Dublin uh
here's a Jewish podcast that Ethan Klein
screaming for I'm screaming for it my
Jewish Brothers by the way I love how I
was like I'm getting on the phone with
all my Jewish Brothers like making fun
of the conspiracy that we're all in
touch why would the Vatican in Dublin
like why first of all
this is Vatican Dublin which is weird I
guess like there's supposed to be like
you know Irish uh you know Irish
Catholics but Irish Catholics would
laugh this off
in my opinion uh usually they're they're
pretty funny
not him I'm like this [ __ ] goober
this loser and also Irish Catholics not
too fond of Nazis like Nick Fuentes I
would say not him not a big fan this
guy's turning it all upside down he's
the Martin Luther King of Catholic
Nazism
we're changing it up he said so I go so
I love my joke about calling my brother
and sisters is actually like real
conspiracy to him his Jewish Brothers to
spear Christ Our Lord again as if as if
that was an option
I liked it because he liked it the first
time who I by the way I'm only 37 uh so
again and not please guys it's not true
I'm 37 okay let's say I'm 42 even yeah
right not even close to Jesus's age to
have speared him before how is he's like
70.
how old is Jesus yeah oh is he seven
years old yeah somewhere around there at
least I know he wasn't alive when I was
he's pretty shredded uh and he's
planning a Mock's execution of Jesus on
Christmas Day do you know who does that
kind of [ __ ] literally Christians yeah
what the [ __ ] like what but you're a Jew
so you're not allowed to do that what
the [ __ ] is that yeah y'all y'all if
that's a problem you guys got big issues
man because these be you've seen what in
the Philippines they got really [ __ ]
crazy about that [ __ ] they'll put his
ass up there all right I got I I don't
know if I can show these pictures I just
learned about this because I was looking
around for pictures of um you know
Recreations of the crucifixion and this
is not uh approved by the Catholic
church at all they they tell them to
stop all the time but there are groups
of uh Catholics in the Philippines that
recreate the crucifixion and they
actually crucify a dude they they nail
somebody to a cross for real swagopino
Pinoy gang
Swag yeah but this is not one of them
this is just I'm sorry Vatican you know
they're they're too metal for you yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah on Easter I think it's
pretty common to recreate the I mean Mel
Gibson made a whole [ __ ] video movie
about it you got a problem talk to him
[ __ ] yeah uh but uh yeah he loves
crucifying Jesus but he also is like
super anti-semitic so he's allowed to do
that right yeah but yeah I mean guys you
would literally wear crosses around your
neck okay if you're trying if you know
if you're not down with the crucifixion
you're in the wrong game crazy I do
again like
acting triggered by the crucifixion is
so funny I'm sorry these guys are like
why can't I say the n-word also oh my
God oh my stars and garters Jewish
podcasts are Ethan Klein said he's gonna
recreate the crucifixion
is that a good thing you should be
thinking bro the only reason your dumb
ass [ __ ] religion is this is because
people come here swear to him yeah the
last time that that happened like didn't
send me flowers onto Easter for me
giving you a [ __ ] life otherwise you
probably still be Jewish like me
a vape from worse than death yeah you
still be a Jew if it wasn't for me and
then what where would you be you're like
you're like a reverse Kanye everyone's
Jew
but not in the Kanye way thank you
or God forbid a Muslim yeah well that's
the last that's the final Saga you know
what I mean that's the third chapter
yeah I'm universally hated by all three
monolithic uh religions well that's why
that's why Muslims say revert not
convert
like Andrew Tate brother Tate uh
reverted into Islam because everyone is
born Muslim they just don't know it yet
that's the game okay I like that yeah
um anyway he's playing he's previously
called for Vatican City to be nuked so
that's fun did you uh no not Newt oh nor
do I have by the way enriched uranium uh
lying around also you mean Vatican
Dublin like that's not for you that's
not he didn't say Dublin he said the
Vatican why do you care yes uh moving on
this is the one we saw
um
uh this one we read even Hassan's
uncomfortable the quartering here's a
good one well Ethan Klein lose all
Partnerships banking relationships and
get kicked off all social media for
making a joke while yay who says that uh
he's not kidding Hitler who has mad
vibes
yeah let's compare the mega bars also
can we just
still on woke 17. the banking
relationships did not fall apart because
uh yadolf decided to say he loves Hitler
okay that happened because he wanted to
terminate the partnership with the bank
these [ __ ] Banks work with like drug
traffickers sex traffickers terrorists
and not the cool kind either like the
whack ones that the CIA works with you
know what I mean like they work with
everybody I don't think they give a [ __ ]
that like uh you know yadoff was saying
I think this image he loves hill bro
what I thought I think that image can
get me killed
no I did I did I did
should I show that you know what you you
killing the Easter Bunny it's so silly
but I can see like 4chan freaks like
doing some like no none of their clothes
and [ __ ] none of those [ __ ]
step foot outside they would perish okay
the moment that they step outside and
the sun is out dude they [ __ ] will
turn into dust yeah
so so this is so is this okay if I have
a uh so it's not Jesus obviously but
there is the thorny crown and he does
have human-like hands it's a man in a
bunny outfit okay let's say we dress up
Jesus's dead body in a bunny outfit
after the fact how about for Lent this
year you guys give up being [ __ ]
sexless nerds dude how about that
then we'd have peace on Earth yeah
give up being a [ __ ] loser okay
um Ethan clients is disgusting animal oh
no not an animal
uh Bruh Bruh returns okay bro you y'all
are looking up [ __ ] six likes now you
know what I mean I thought
damn it had no movement because even the
other even the other like Nazi nerds are
like okay bro this [ __ ] is like kind of
whack you know everybody does some of
them are funny Ethan Klein will plan a
mock execution of Christ on Christmas
repent child of the devil that is funny
Repent Jesus
it's also kind of wild to see like the
the circuit you know what I mean and how
how it trickles into like uh people who
launder white supremacist talking points
like I saw one down there there's
another one
he's welcome to do so and unlike in an
Islamic country he will not be murder
for doing so he's like yeah let's use
this as an opportunity to [ __ ] [ __ ]
on myself a lot of that what a great
country we are and isn't it incredible
how tolerant we Christians are wait what
he's like he's still
yeah a lot of you mad about it or not
like yeah super interesting because
you're like we're tolerant for now you
[ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] you better
watch it like go down I want to see this
one other guy Ethan Klein trying to
speedrun the second Holocaust just for a
joke about this I thought that was
pretty lame
bro isn't that dude like what's up with
that guy I mean
he he does a podcast out of his closet
literally I'm not even oh okay that
makes their shirts hanging behind him he
said he's like I'm not even kidding yeah
that's not a joke he literally
oh he doesn't even have a two billion
dollar Studio like we do that's crazy
yes oh that was pretty weird oh you
gotta you gotta go to the wide shot to
flex on him dude that's messed up
oh dude God damn whoa
so much space you guys whoa whoa
man
yeah so there's that you know fun stuff
she's got his own ecosystem in here I
don't even know there's like animals and
stuff flying around it's crazy yeah but
anyway congrats on winning the news
category I'm just happy that um you beat
Phil DeFranco
[Laughter]
yeah well even if he won like it would
have been like I won you know what I
mean because because of the thumb bows
well I have more thumbs so I wouldn't
yeah okay well you know that's true that
is true actually I don't know if that's
true it might not be true no I think in
the last like a few months you might be
taking them I might I might have but
yeah but who's who's counting not me or
me I'm clearly I'm counting I'm winning
cracker but lifetime I'm winning so come
on okay well I you know I I gained
prominence in the in the circuit
recently I got years away from me okay
I'm like number four all time that's
crazy who's number one pewdiepie
uh Mr Beast PewDiePie is up there
someone on Reddit posted uh November uh
16 days ago basically that we have 45 or
you have 45 Hassan has 16.
it's that we're that total yeah total
ground lifetime total I'm surprised only
at 45. I have 16 only and you have 45
you're like that's Michael crazy bro
that's true yeah I'm Michael Jordan in
my Prime you're Michael Jordan playing
baseball
oh that's harsh man that's messed up uh
Trump is number one with 68 PewDiePie
number two with 58 then Logan Paul 49.
Logan yeah you're number four Ethan at
46.
hi there do something crazy and I'd fear
him again
it's not happening bro
yeah but you you so you were up against
uh in your category
Andrew Callahan I was yeah you were up
for uh um uh Philip DeFranco
but you know the one that I think is a
little homophobic of you to beat is gay
news
you beat gay news I think you need to
pass your award to them yeah it's messed
up
I'm sorry gay news homophobic a little
bit slow at a time like this I get a
little fruity though you know I get
zesty with it I am gay
in that moment I felt gay
did you feel disabled today I feel uh
yeah I felt like an immigrant worker
that's what I felt like uh [ __ ] we have
to keep our country gate prepared
[Laughter]
that's great
uh yeah so congratulations on that one
but but you got yada yada just like our
category they explained your ass yeah I
didn't even know I won because I was in
the back like uh you know
doing things for the Streamys that were
more important like uh my announcements
for the actual awards that matter you
know what I mean so and all the I was up
for two awards that actually do matter
where you get like a moment to speak on
stage and stuff I didn't win those yeah
uh I was up against uh for stream of the
year I was up against like everyone
I shall speak Kai Cenac Kai day Ludwig
Pokemon quaggity Tarik Valkyrie xuc
um and then uh for for just chatting I
was up against Bruce drop him off shouts
out to Bruce he's great uh Kai sinat
quackity and XC and they [ __ ] clap me
you know yeah I got destroyed by Kai and
xcc on on two different categories I
mean Kai Kai had a big year so we loved
that for him yeah and uh whatever who
cares but the ultimate remember I always
wanted to get you to interview him
but a long time ago you're trying to
what get you to interview him a while
ago you were I don't remember I because
I don't think I knew who he was yeah you
did not you think it's too late now you
think that boat is sailed he might be
down to do it he might be down different
audience yeah there you go we'll reach
out to reach across the aisle you know I
mean people help people
break that down Dan
well we okay we have reached out
apparently he's big time does oh he has
I don't know whatever we'll talk about
it later okay I have never spoken to him
um so anyway
uh congratulations
moving on
also yesterday I don't know if you know
this was D-Day Sean Spicer the former
White House Press Secretary the king of
all
uh news today is D-Day
it only lives in infamy if we remember
and share the story of sacrifice with
the Next Generation what hashtag D-Day
December 7th the only problem D-Day is
on June 6th
why did he what is happening
Sean Spicer and then he I don't know
what's happening I mean yesterday was a
different it was Pearl Harbor yeah and I
think he just got complete does he think
Pearl Harbor is D-Day no I think he just
got them swapped I I think he just
goofed but I don't understand why you
have to tweet it anyway like no no like
you don't see me tweeting at 9 11. you
know what I mean like today you don't
tweet on 911 no I tweet on 9 11. I was
lying where were you just at least I was
I was dancing in the rooftops in New
Jersey I saw I knew I saw you there yeah
and I was spearing Jesus yeah
yes shout out Sean Spicer
um it's D-Day every day let's be real
this they will will only live in infamy
if we remember and share the story of
the sacrament it's like the one it's the
one good military intervention so like
they have to talk about it all the time
yeah we are still riding that wave okay
the D-Day wave yeah I mean beating the
Nazis is like all we have and they which
put the way like you know there was some
heavy lifting being done on the [ __ ]
Eastern front Okay let's not talk about
the Eastern Front okay they did what
they did and we did what they we did
okay we're gonna stop dissing the Nazi
yeah we gotta stop you know what I mean
it's just
don't take that away from us Sean Spicer
is already changing D-Day also uh
maybe he meant P day
like Pearl Harbor Day P day infamy oh a
commonly used acronym yeah he says I'm
just trying to save him dude
that's what he said about that's right
we're doing a covid show okay so bro
have you seen this video because you're
in front of the a treat of your life oh
wait oh that's awesome what's what's
Dave gonna say now so Dave Rubin the
saddest most pathetic self-hating man uh
to ever grace this Earth uh has doing a
show with covet he's in Florida so it's
all good
wait that's so weird like dude wait but
it's not like he's gonna get anybody to
come anyway now No One's Gonna show up
no listen everybody showed up watch this
it's the best uh so I do have kovid
that's right we're doing a covid show uh
I said to my guys last night I said guys
just FYI I've got kovid I'm not
pressuring anyone to come into work is
what it is you know I think at this
point it's just like a little cold or a
flu but you know I want to be respectful
of my guys I don't force them to get
vaccinated and I don't force them to be
in a room with me if I have covid and to
quote them directly I wrote it down what
you both said when I said uh you know if
you want to come into work Connor you
said I laugh in the face of death and
Phoenix you said screw you old man which
I thought was very uh that's how much
these people love coming to work so we
are in here Clyde is in here with us
today uh and mostly I'm just gonna be
spending it's a beautiful day in Florida
it's about 75 live and sunny I'm going
to be hanging out in the backyard I'll
hit the gym for a little bit maybe do
some swimming I'll shoot this
[ __ ] say he's going to the gym
while he has covered as Florida you have
to go
no it's illegal for him not the old folk
song it's illegal for him not to go to
the gym while he is why would he even
say that like yeah I can't wait I can't
wait to spread it to everybody first of
all he's betraying once again his own
like tiny little [ __ ] moral compass
that he created in this world where he's
like on the one hand I informed my I
informed my workers that I have coveted
so they don't have to show up to work on
the other hand I will not be informing
the gym that I'm showing up
uh with covet what kind of weird vert
like this is virtue signaling now I'm
going to the gym with coven yeah
yeah okay great it keeps going of course
I'm gonna survive oh and more important
than anything else I you don't have to
worry about me you really don't have to
worry about me folks I'm unpacked he's
unfactured I'm unboxed I'm unboosted I
am I'm pure blood I'm good to go I'm
gonna be okay I'll drink some water
there's a little lemon in the jump cut
to three days
Reuben dies a coven I mean first of all
I think he's lying like he's definitely
vaccines he's gay yeah so the vaccine
already took effect because you know I
so so you know so you know he got
vaccinated wait what does that mean
vaccine turns you gay Oh I thought that
was just the frogs yeah
um so that's one to turn the freaking
team
um yeah there's not even a two I just
don't believe that he's [ __ ] uh pure
blood
you've had a vaccine in your life what I
was gonna say is like I love
one of the funniest comments I saw in
the aftermath of my streaming news
victory was like all the sweatiest Nerds
were mad and one of them quote tweeted
it and said I hope the vaccine kills him
soon oh yeah get him and and five
billion other people on Earth
he's just like he's like I know it's
gonna happen but I hope it's soon I love
that it's something for all of us man
yeah they have to turn on the uh the 5G
kill grid is the thing they haven't
flipped the switch yet oh wait we need
to be playing the disclaimer yeah so I I
meant to tell you our last episode got
demonetized because YouTube said quote
we let Kanye run on too long without
commentary we didn't make it clear
enough that we disavow Nick Fuentes and
yay because we let him talk for too long
yeah it must have been me saying like I
love Kanye West like I agree with
everything he's ever said yeah we just
were silently nodding it was Ian's
presence so now we have this uh yeah Ian
you gotta that's well we have this now
okay so you switch to Zach when you
throw that up geez
so anytime we watch Kanye or Nick
Fuentes or anyone we just need to make
it clear to everybody watching right
that this is the dumbass alert we
disavowed everything said by this loose
okay but I'm a bit of a dumbass too so
yeah yeah
yo Dom what's up everybody it's the
dumptake uh siren as well so dumb
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Dan mother [ __ ] so yeah there
you go thank you that's a nice little
touch we got there I like that they
didn't think like I I I don't understand
why they would ever get the impression
that we were Pro Kanye or anything he
said in any meaningful capacity yeah
they said it's basically re-uploading a
band clip if we don't interrupt him we I
don't think we even let it play for more
than like five years I've seen our show
what the [ __ ] it's like we can't get
over three and a half seconds without
you know pausing at first he's like you
went four minutes with unpausing I was
like that's literally impossible I
laughed out loud when Ethan told me that
that's yeah it wasn't even here
physically not possible no you should
did you look at the clip was it what was
the actual timer probably like 30
seconds there is
yeah yeah oh we were talking over it
while it was going on okay the specific
one was the cook the uh Cookie Monster
Nick Fuentes uh analogy well you needed
uh you needed to see the full context to
understand what the [ __ ] he was saying
you know what I mean so so apparently uh
we we co-signed the Cookie Monster clip
according to YouTube so yeah okay okay
dude that's [ __ ] nuts yeah so we have
the overlay now but meanwhile
um
Crowder and Alex Jones if you can
believe it are actually trying to
distance themselves from Kanye and
Fuentes and you know that's [ __ ]
crazy you don't have to think about it
dude
cowards here's two great minds
you know this is so interesting because
a lot of these conservative people do
hate Jews like Alex Jones fans Crowder
fans they're gonna have opinions about
Jews and now this is causing such a rift
in the conservative world because Kanye
is just like making them choose one side
or the other you with Hitler or not bro
just you know what I mean it's it's
great I love it I mean I you know come
here and shut up I don't like you know
the anti-Semitism but
above about Hitler first and let him get
it out of his system even if he did it
right I was saying hey let's do
something different let's let's show him
your intellectual side let's let you
know let's get into a bunch of issues
and I had all these issues in front of
me he goes why don't you just set those
aside we're not getting into that I was
like okay he's letting me know he's in
control and so I figured after an hour
at least he would let me kind of then
bring up some topics I wanted uh but you
kind of had
he was like uh the entire time I was
trying to talk about
the MRNA vaccine and how the Jews were
giving it to each other and and
therefore can't be a global Jewish
conspiracy out there and he was like no
he just wanted to say he loves Hitler
that's exactly what happened he brought
up the the vaccines this old man he is
so washed like the kids have moved on
old man they moved on to Hitler now okay
he just kept bringing up the [ __ ]
vaccines over and over again and like
Kanye West is vaccinated doesn't give a
[ __ ] you know what I mean it's just like
yeah whatever no let's talk about Hitler
my favorite guy yeah he's like we don't
need a soft pedal this year tomorrow
let's just say it
from the Baby Hitler uh because Nick
Fuentes Baby Hitler I thought that was
funny why do you have baby Hitler on and
didn't say anything mean about him then
doesn't that kind of make you a lame ass
dude yeah yeah the Baby Hitler uh of
Nick Fuentes over there uh you know that
was a joke Jimmy Kimmel made like where
have I seen this seen this foreign
Jazz was really a Nazi lover uh but
there's a real creepy factor with the
Hitler stuff yeah so Nick Fuentes is
real creepy I mean he is he's like a
gremlin on top of [ __ ] loving you
know Hitler he he is he's like such a
[ __ ] unlikable goober and of course
if you are a fan uh of his you are not
going to understand this because like he
has this frequency that he hits that uh
that that Target the exact same kind of
gross [ __ ] loser
like if you're a fan of his you're
probably just as gross and just as
sweaty of a gremlin yeah right
speaking of which I I can't believe he
just name dropped salacious crumb in
there this is like the most obscure Star
Wars character you could possibly yeah
they're the same like solely Marvel
consumers that they [ __ ] knowledge
on top of the Hut and there's salacious
crumbs how did they even figure out his
name
dude I mean that's like hey the the
4chan guys would call this bug man
behavior you know what I mean
consumption of this variety so yeah
there was um actually I wanted to watch
these these were some of the clips you
were reacting to when you got banned and
they're really good uh we gotta throw up
the bad take alert yeah get these ready
yeah so get you know I got to say Gavin
was actually asking him
he really was asking him the good
questions that are going to provoke an
answer that I'm actually really curious
to for example he goes do you hate all
Jewish people bro what are the good
questions that he asked was literally
like the Jewish question and the final
that's what I wanted to hear that's like
what are you gonna do how are you gonna
deal with all these [ __ ] Jews no but
that's what he said that's what the
question I actually wanted to hear
because everyone's just treating him
like a sideshow so it's like okay so
what is your I want to know Kanye what
are you gonna do he hasn't thought it
through yeah he he doesn't no he did he
has he said he would enslave all the
Jews yeah yeah yeah and place them under
Mass surveillance and in work camps
maybe I don't know no one's ever thought
that one before very unique violence
just a subservience uh systematic
subservience yeah but I actually
appreciate these questions being asked
because I want to know like how deep and
dark Kanye's mind goes because right now
he's just talking about how he loves
Hitler anyway throw up the uh the the
you know blacks are over represented in
violent crime but when you meet an
individual black person you don't apply
that you start with a fresh lady I love
someone do you do that with Jews I did
not love that I did not love when he
said when he paused I was being
sarcastic YouTube when I said like I
love them I love that uh what no that
wasn't me I love that was going on why
this eval has gone I disavow you Hassan
okay well yeah he goes a black
person yeah you can tell where his
heart's at you know blacks are
overrepresented in violent crime but
when you meet an individual black person
you don't apply that you start with a
fresh slate every time you meet someone
do you do that with Jews nope
yes I like no I like that I want to know
so okay you hate all Jews so I like to
know that thank you yeah I mean he's
pretty old he's pretty obvious but it's
so specific they love it though they're
like they're yucking it up they're like
Ah that's crazy me too bro
well it's a crazy thing to say yeah
this intervention isn't going very well
yeah so so that so there's a really
incredible take
sensor.tv by the way and if you watch
our clip we will censor you so they
that's why they're called censored uh
because they censor people anyway yeah
they sense their opposition they were
not you know they were not fond of of
what I have to say dude this is my the
craziest [ __ ] clip that came out of
this here's Nick Fuentes saying that
when he was a kid kids loved Hitler yeah
I said even yeah this is like what I
never knew any kid that loved Hitler but
I does say something about your
upbringing well I don't think that the
Jews are particularly ethnomasochistic
if you look at all the blowback to yay
they're they're very defensive they're
very paranoid you could say yeah I
wonder why gradually paranoid about
threats to their well-being I'm
pathologically paranoid meanwhile
Kanye's like we need to uh make all
juice subservient slaves to Christians
he's like it's it's so weird Jewish
people are paranoid about anti-Semitism
while I'm trying to spread anti-semitic
theories so we can do the Holocaust 2
Electric Boogaloo yeah like yeah yeah I
wonder why people are paranoid it's
pathological at this point
I agree with you that liberalism is a
poison I'm not a liberal and I think the
liberalism has poisoned the well for
white people but if you look at white
kids there's nothing I don't think
intrinsic in white people that makes
them hate themselves like when I was a
kid kids loved Hitler in the sense that
we see the videos and we see the
propaganda and the symbols and there's
something compelling about it just on an
aesthetic level I've never heard that
before when you were a little kid like
eight years old
kids love Hitler yeah the kids is
[ __ ] the Nazi youth I think
come on weren't you all weren't you all
in the same classes when you were a kid
where you Zig hired and had the
swastikas on the wall you guys can do
that Hitler I've never heard that before
when you were a little kid like eight
years old all your friends like it not
maybe not eight years old but on 4chan
and on the internet yeah yeah yeah very
popular okay those weren't kids dogs you
were being groomed yeah that's not
normal life you just described bro yeah
oh you know I like farts head where all
the cool kids hang out and Forge hand
kids loved Hitler uh yeah yeah yeah
it is funny that these guys are calling
Jews paranoid but they're like
hysterically paranoid about white
genocide yeah we're being displaced
yeah Nick played Jews and Nazis instead
of cops and robbers you know what I mean
so it's a little bit of a yeah and then
here's where Kanye says that you should
be subservient uh slaves to to
Christians here's the Jewish question
thank you for the dumbass eval we just
we dumbass about the main issue is that
Christ is King Christ is the true king
of Israel Christ is the king of all
Kings yeah if you don't believe in Jesus
Christ you are wrong and anyone that
doesn't believe in Jesus Christ should
not be in control or in any influence to
anything that America produces be it
media technology Gavin's sweating
because he's like I don't know if I
believe medicine prisons whole thing's
kind of fake to me Gavin's like this
guy's taking it kind of far yeah gav is
like you know I invent advice right like
that's I'm definitely Godless
right right prisons
if you do not believe in Christ and
you're not following Christ and the
decisions that you make you should have
no influence on that
well that's going to be a tough thing to
Institute so so you're president of the
United States I mean the Hitler thing
does not hurt your campaign
dude he's like he's like you know uh the
logistics of that is not a bad idea yeah
just she's gonna be implausible yeah
yeah I mean yeah I like it on Face the
funniest part about this is like you see
three different like uh types of of you
know white supremacists white
nationalists anti-semitic goobers on
there and like Gavin is trying to appear
sane yeah because he's like trying to
put the dog whistles back on and like
Nick Fuentes can't stop himself from
like going full a full-blown blown
bullhorn God damn it I can't talk
um and and Kanye is just on a different
level of that he just says it exactly
what it is that's what I yeah there's
actually the clip with the Jewish
question it was in one of those threads
y'all
where he says what do we do about it
my for my friend uh
my friend Adolf wait what's wait what's
a Jewish a stereotypical Jewish name
Moses maybe my friend Moses and then
this happened ow what do we do about it
wait is how we Jewish
uh he is Joshua okay of Howie Mandel
from the show
oh one of the funniest ones one of the
funniest parts of the interview was when
they were like you know 80 to 90 percent
of Hollywood is Jews
like straight up that cannot be it's
just not true that's insane dude what
the [ __ ] but they were like
they literally brought it up as though
it was like real and not a single person
was like uh I don't know man it's like
like our Jewish people overrepresented
in like or are is there a higher
percentage of Jewish people hold on hold
on throw up the disclaimer
okay well regardless yes that is true
it's not 90 and uh having a higher
percentage of Jewish people in in one
field does not necessarily imply that
there is a Jewish conspiracy and that
they're all acting in a monolithic
capacity unless the monolith that you
are referencing is capitalism in which
case you know that that transcends
ethnic boundaries uh entirely is just
people motivated by Capital also there's
not a dumb ass take that's a good take
okay all right that's the truth just
being safe just being safe okay no but
there's there's lots of fields where
certain uh groups are over represented
you know what I mean it's not like that
happens right
yeah I mean they want wasps to return to
like having 98 of control from like
[ __ ] the the 85 that they have
currently you know what I mean but it
doesn't matter because like even if you
are even if you are a Protestant like
they just say you're Jewish if you're an
executive like it it literally is like
well and when we were interviewing
Andrew Callahan he goes oh yeah I've
been getting tons of anti-Semitic
comments yeah yeah they were saying he's
Jewish yeah no no no no yeah so of
course everybody's Jewish when literally
you think everyone's Jewish yeah he
brought up BlackRock as an example he
was like or Vanguard as an example he's
like Vanguard CEO like you know Jewish
Banking and I looked it up and the
dude's name is like Patty mcphurl o'hary
or something like you know what I mean
I'm like come on dude of course yeah it
was like Buckley Mortimer Buckley
something like it's the most the the
most Christian name you can get yeah
it's kind of awesome you can basically
just say that about anyone and they'll
believe it yeah so here's the Jewish
question uh so you're president of the
United States the the Hitler thing does
not hurt your campaign first how's my
campaign okay it helps your campaign
you're in office it's day one and
they're gonna lose you someone walks in
and they go so what are we gonna do
about these Jews
what do you say what do you mean do
about them is there any action involved
like they they're overly represented and
met lots of people who don't believe in
Christ I would I would probably wager
that in your average Hospital in New
York
maybe a third or less Believe In Christ
so are you suggesting we get rid of
two-thirds of the doctors not get rid of
like not violently get rid of them
I hear them
I think that Jews are very intelligent
but they don't deserve to be in charge
of everything because they don't put
Christ
and how do you legislate that they need
to work for Christians Jews should work
for Christians I hire a Jewish person in
a second if I knew they weren't a spy
and I collected their phone and follow
them to their house and have a camera
all in their living room
yeah
you just like you put them in work camps
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a
good good solution Kanye it's funny it
is funny isn't it
I love that no one's ever no one's ever
thought about that what a unique some
might say final solution to the Jewish
question yeah so I can totally
understand why you got the DMC on that
oh clearly there's not you had no valid
criticism of any of that no of course
not I was like in a barge through there
I was I was clapping like a seal yeah
yeah throughout the entire process
um so moving on from all these goons we
have some good news actually uh which is
that in Georgia
uh Warnock
won and thank God for that although it
was very close
um and Herschel almost won which have
been I think black pilled a lot of
people but no he lost so [ __ ] yeah and I
love you Herschel Herschel yeah this was
Trump's pick
and they it was so close they went to a
runoff but uh
Warnock clap them cheeks
yeah I mean Brian Camp uh had a massive
dub over uh Walker on the same exact
ticket so he had a he had a [ __ ] load
more votes than Herschel Walker so
people had the capacity to vote for uh
Hershey Walker down ballot and they
refused to do so that's in livelihood
that they would do that and the runoff
was way way you know it was close than I
thought it'd be though to be honest and
there are certain points where like
Herschel was ahead and I was like oh God
please not this timeline but yeah I love
I mean it's it's nice to see that these
absolutely
dog [ __ ] candidates that Trump has been
putting forward are not winning and just
thank God for that man
Warnock is not even like one of the
worst Democrats either he's like decent
I mean that's not saying too much I
don't really like the Democratic party
but like he's a he's an all right
senator
on the more Progressive side I would say
here's the cope from Donald because that
was his hand-picked candidate so he
takes these things personally by the way
almost every single Evangelical voted
for Herschel Walker
whose only experience with Christianity
is like thinking that he's Jesus or God
because of his CPE against a [ __ ]
Reverend uh so there's that the man who
abandoned his kids his child is
literally on Twitter saying this man
abandoned me as a child yeah who uh has
reportedly uh has like done domestic
abuse done domestic abuse gotten gotten
several abortions almost at a shootout
with the police
oh that's nice yeah oh well almost come
almost
thinks he's a cop what was the final
tally on the vote on the abortions oh
how many because it kept going up I
forget like how many oh we still don't
know I think you just kind of you know
as time goes on it's too too many to
count yeah
yeah so Trump taking all this personally
it's his it's his pick right so it makes
him look bad he promoted him big time
our country's in big trouble what a mess
of course yeah
the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
continues over and over again and the
people of this country aren't going to
take it much longer okay Donnie
not looking good for you buddy take the
gloves off Donald start [ __ ] you know
laying into to the stinky Rhonda I wanna
I wanna hear it
it's coming don't worry they still have
a lot of time little Ronda
to my anyway
um
yeah it's it's good man there's the the
Republican Party really is fractured
right now and it's really nice to see
that uh they're reaping what they sowed
on this
um speaking of reaping what they sowed
here's Charlie Kirk this the man with
the smallest face possibly ever I mean
smaller and listen I don't yeah his like
my hairline gets stronger his face gets
smaller every time every time he becomes
more races his face gets tinier and
tinier soon we will not be able to see
his face now listen I think that
everyone is beautiful and has a
beautiful soul and what I'm about to say
she does not have a beautiful soul
Charlie Kirk does not have a beautiful
soul let alone a soul We Are All God's
Children oh no Charlie stop do some
social justice activism do something
yeah bro fix is the gayest generation in
American history
it's true I'm I felt gay
no but I but what I was going to say is
just basically with peace and love he is
this one of the strangest looking people
I've ever seen in my life and I don't
mean that as a derogatory I'm just it's
just a matter of fact yeah you're just
trying to say he's ugly hot like Timothy
chalamet he's just yeah yeah yeah that's
what I'm trying to say he's ugly harmful
careful
oh do we have Timothy shallow man oh
yeah there's seashell fans in this
office he's ugly hot I mean he said he's
hot
or is he hot ugly
much to think about yeah and I prefer
the less pressure label ugly ugly I felt
ugly which is what I the moniker I give
myself yeah come on oh God
yeah I mean dude I I shouldn't say
anything
bro it doesn't matter he's like a sex
icon super successful you know movie
star he's fine it's just not for me
that's it not for my case well he look
he did a good transformation I mean he's
tall and now he's like super jacked and
now it's just like Daddy Ben swallow
that's what they call him yeah but so so
as we are saying Charlie Kirk is ugly
hot
and well so Charlie Kirk spent the last
two years
um bitching and moaning about how the
election was rigged that mail-in voting
is fraudulent and now once this guy lost
in Georgia he's getting all these emails
from his viewers saying I didn't vote
and I'm not going to vote anymore
because the whole system's rigged and
what's the point
I love that whoa where'd they get that
idea so Charlie's trying to figure out
what to do here uh uh as his face gets
smaller the only thing that's funnier
than this is if they like literally
start a new campaign where it's like you
have to vote illegally
because you know the Democrats are doing
it and then they like actually go to
jail they'll be like the the very wise
documented instance of oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
Adam's a fan he's in the chat and he
donated sorry I think we live here
you're a great actor you're a great
actor you tell me this man ain't [ __ ]
stacked
come on now
all right it's just
that is very hard further proves like my
fingers nips
I think but hey you know what do I know
yeah I didn't know he was a veteran I'm
disrespecting a veteran right now so
it's a twofer on D-Day on the day after
D-Day that's the put the disclaimer up
on Hassan please
on p-day go ahead and say what's your
opinion on Adam Driver again big Adam
Driver is not for me okay but I think he
seems like a nice guy
I disavow this YouTube I disavow should
I just like hit some some of the talking
points like about BTS and stuff while
this shit's on me yeah sure I mean I
just about wait what if I say I love BTS
and BTS is the best take it away take it
away oh you took that away so quick he
took that down God damn you guys are
sharp you're you're fast well they they
gotta babysit me so they immediately
took that away while I was doing the
Heart
by the way thank you uh chairman meow
for the gifted love that name
thank you
so um yeah let's watch this
this I was in the movie 2000 mules I
sympathize with all of the sentiment
thoughts actually
are not as important you could have very
angry thoughts towards the system it is
actions that I will Instead address you
could say oh this system is corrupt it's
terrible
I'm going to go vote fine
right thing you've allowed your thoughts
to manifest into what I would consider
to be in immoral action
someone says Charlie I thought I thought
you were kidding when you said people
weren't voting until you read these
emails no you should see I'm reading
them on air and by the way I'm tweeting
out some of these emails so you could
see them yourself there's no shot that
it was like a noticeable amount of
people though I don't think well
it ended up being like a hundred
thousand vote difference when it was
like down to like 10 000 or something
then I can see that yeah it's like no
you just ran a bad campaign a lot of
this stuff is not as complicated
sometimes it can be very complicated and
other times it can be very simple
and I think if you put a guy like
Herschel Walker up there wanna revise
okay no I take it back what the [ __ ] is
that did you photoshop that that's
insane that's his body
dude they need to stop letting Hollywood
use steroids man it's op
PA he's all Natty also I don't want to
[ __ ] hear from another insult ever
again like oh my God I can't like he gym
Max look at him look at him dude
look at him yeah he did that bro yeah no
he did the anavar essential tenant he
just took he just took the uh deliver
King supplements bro
that's crazy yeah yeah he's hot hot
that's a nice in that one I told you so
thank you all I need to see
you [ __ ] right jack
oh well that dude [ __ ] oh that's not
what that means but it I mean
he's attractive I wouldn't say I'd [ __ ]
him but he's a good looking guy you
wouldn't throw it back for Adam Driver
looking like that nah George Clooney but
not him
so you're saying you're gay
no
no I felt okay wrong with that
I felt gay I felt good
I mean it is a blessing I I don't want
to get back into rehashing old [ __ ] but
like if you go to the gym you're gay as
[ __ ] okay if you work out extensively
you are so gay it's just that is what it
is you you develop an appreciation for
the male physique no matter what happens
that's gonna be all over uh Tick Tock
tomorrow selectively edited
I mean it's true and there's nothing
wrong with it but it is a shame for no
that's what I'm saying is they're going
to take if you go to the gym you're so
gay and it'll just be that and then it's
gonna like hard cut to some dude working
out with a girl right
I am yeah that's a [ __ ] list no I
think most a lot of the Jim Bros on Tick
Tock are are actually you know pretty
funny nowadays maybe the ones I see at
least like those are like the smaller
like old school like I want to be red
pilled MRA guy gym guys but like most of
the big like gym accounts
at least the ones I follow the ones I
interact with like they're pretty funny
they're not like and Bradley are dogs
now I don't know if you knew yeah like
Bradley Martin would take that and make
a joke about it
I think by the way
um
I got a message from Steve we'll do it
oh [ __ ] and honestly it was really sweet
I just want to say this what did he say
have to
think they were defending my honor
against your hordes of fans boating 98
it was 90. let's be real let's be honest
about the results uh some
he said I apologize for what I said
about you and your wife it wasn't right
what I said what did he say about he
called Ela ugly and said that I'm fat it
was just like stupid stuff but like but
I thought it was really nice of him
we're trying to work out a time for him
and Brad to come on the
the show together you should bro I
thought it was really nice don't bring
the dogs on that episode just to be safe
well don't bring the dogs to the studio
and that I really should bring Donnie
just to prove that their relationship is
platonic
have sex with Donnie
yeah so I thought that was really nice
so yeah so I I was Touched By by the way
I always thought and not like Donnie was
touched but like an emotional way yeah
you know liver King never apologized to
me
he sent me a personal opinion yeah wait
did I say that on it yeah well you I
don't know if you said it on air you
told me he flexed on me a little bit
Yeah well he messaged you after the fact
that you guys are Primal and I'm so
Primal [ __ ] beta cuck and then you
guys bonded over that but then once he
got outed he sent me on Instagram a
personal apology he said uh
[ __ ] I just read it sorry Tick Tock I'll
be right back
be right back Ted I mean I can read it
you sent it to me
oh okay good then I'll just I'll let you
do that if you can pull if you know
where it is let me pull it up let me
pull up our conversation
you can do it
excuse me Jesus Christ
in the meantime uh let's take a look at
this
here I'll read it oh God this really
disturbs me cam made this and liver King
here oh you didn't do the progression
though should I read it go ahead yeah
read the lyricing here yeah he's doing
an apology man to man because you and
Hassan gave me a platform to fight for
my message and I was dishonest with you
and your audience about steroids this
was the ultimate subprimal act which I
respect like that's a that's a nice
genuine heartfelt apology I thought so
yeah except I didn't receive one I know
I [ __ ] it all up I lied about it dot
dot I've used steroids and I'm currently
on steroids I fully owned that I [ __ ]
up I take ownership and will become a
better human
I've been crushed to a new low and in
time I will rise to new heights I think
he's saying like he's gonna more
steroids experimental leg lengthening
surgery I think I gotta get rid of that
back fat yeah before you come on next
thank you for the support the criticism
the love the hate and above all the
Loyalty liver King out I don't know what
he means
[Music]
I didn't I never pledge allegiance like
that I wanna I wanna point out that he
he called uh lying about being on
steroids the ultimate subprimal act he
had previously referred to 911 as the
ultimate subprime
it's my 9 11.
when I found out the liver King was on
on the juice where were you and when
when liver King got exposed oh I was at
the gym I felt in my knees everyone in
the gym felt a disturbance yeah I fell
to my knees like immediately I was like
oh no I actually invited him I said
liver
I appreciate the heart he went on Andrew
Schultz before you to [ __ ] address
wait he already is on an apology tour he
did it he went on Andrew Schultz
immediately [ __ ] real [ __ ] Andrew
dude swiping our guests dude no shot
he's already on a part so I said yo I
appreciate the apology come on the show
let's talk about the
you know whatever I want to talk about
it but he he goes talking about the
allegations yeah let's talk about the
allegations liver
now will I want to see the blood work
bro I want to see your cholesterol
that's all out of the bag here is what
liver King's doing in the meantime
yes something about Shield connect cold
Sun fight and bond he's wearing more
clothes now either the liver king or the
Simba king I noticed he's wearing a
picture
I think he's converting to Islam like
Kate now I'm glad you made that joke
because I was noting that as well this
is this is the past God that line is so
[ __ ] sick though well yeah that's
super unethical that Line's for sure had
its claws pulled maybe even its teeth so
that and yeah and that looks like
freedom that looks like an extremely
endangered species of lion so I'm sure
it looks like like a specific yeah I
don't know if it's old or if it's like
albino or something no they definitely
declawed it they [ __ ] up they [ __ ]
that thing up that's super sad and
[ __ ] up to be honest yeah not that
Lion King cares about ethical treatment
of animals you saw that Abomination that
created on Halloween no what is that can
I even show that oh no I did see it on
the red on the subreddit no don't show
that yeah it's pretty gruesome that is
demonic bro yeah that [ __ ] was crazy and
like I love eating animals you know what
I mean I and it was still it's one of
those things where you're like okay
that's a bridge too far
dude because it's like you you didn't
need to do that so his chef like a turd
ducking they took like the head of a
bobcat and sewed it onto the body of I
don't they took all these body parts and
sewed it together
it was honestly an Abomination like I
get that you we eat animals and all that
and the treatment but like to actually
go out of your way to create this
uh yeah it was gross um really [ __ ] up
but also thank you to um
chairman ma oh wait I already said that
thank you you know what Alan Christian
is like not related but did you know
there's like people that [ __ ] like
try to domesticate hyenas
that's crazy it's yeah you look so cool
hyenas are super dangerous yeah they I
think they have like the strongest
pound-for-pound jaw bite of any mammal
hyenas do yeah
you could definitely fact check back
and they're technically closer to I mean
they have their own group they're not
canines but they're closer to felines
than canines
right right yeah I mean they're super
more you know
uh
uh go ahead back check me on my hyenas
stats
the hippopotamus has the strongest bite
of all per pound that's PSI so that
would mean pound oh I guess you're
saying yeah yeah yeah there's a diet but
bottomus weighs a lot more I see hippos
are also the most deadly I think right
yeah they kill more people than one of
the deadliest dude yeah it's so sad
because they're the cutest oh my God
hippos I [ __ ] love I love hippos so
much I want to pet him so bad but I'm
kind of down with that they're like dude
we're living our best life and nobody's
gonna [ __ ] with us even alligators
running fear from hippos yeah but I just
I don't know there's just some as a big
human I I there's something I appreciate
about big animals like that oh is that a
baby hippo yeah baby tell me I can't pet
that you're crazy I don't give a [ __ ] if
I lose the arm dude I'm petting that
[ __ ] bucket is required look at this
dummy dude look at how [ __ ] silly
this thing is oh oh
yeah baby hippos are so cute oh my God
even adult hippos I find to be very cute
I don't know why no they're they've got
mad Vibes dude hippos are cool as [ __ ]
yeah they're chill as [ __ ] I wish I
could be friends with a hippo
what are hit baby hippocodes they're
called calfs just FYI yeah God damn it
dude I mean
I don't know I I also love Capybaras too
but that's a basic classic one but
hippos are probably the weirdest animal
that I like
I've said this before I think on this
show as well but like one of my most
unrealistic idiotic takes is that like I
could be chill with a bear like in the
wild I don't know if a bear came up to
me in the wild like we we'd Vibe like
the bear would notice my vibes and be
like oh that's cool yeah I mean well
there was bear man he did was uh you
know he lived out your dream he was uh
horrifically torn apart by a bear but
yeah like but the Vibes were off on that
night you know what I mean like it's
just like
if you if you steady have Good Vibes I
feel like Bears will will vibe back and
they won't kill you
so I it's I'm not finding any list of
pound-for-pound rating but I'm reading
which animals have the strongest bite
and you're you might be right I do see
that a Jaguar has a stronger than a
hyena though
they wait around British what the [ __ ]
is that
who say the animal name again Jaguar
Jaguar
no I feel like they say Jaguar Jaguar
like aluminum
all right let's finish up my my British
side oh my God we went on so many
different I forgot that we were on this
yeah we were actually watching a video
yeah but um Charlie I mean this is
cooler to think about I like to think
about hippos it's very boring he is yeah
I mean they do have similar faces very
crunched very cute no how dare you lots
of crunching hippos are cute as [ __ ]
Charlie Kirk looks like an Abomination
well he looks like liver King's Chef
maybe put pieced them together from
different parts not
all right let's watch it
the Maga movement is committing suicide
in front of our very eyes because
of and if you extrapolate that that
means there and we see it in the numbers
we see in the data millions of people
that have said we are no longer going to
vote
because of cynicism yeah weird and if
you L if you look at
the sentiment I share the sentiment by
the way when I went and voted in Arizona
I even said boy I hope this counts
but I still voted right it's the action
that matters right anyone here for
marriage you can have the thought I'm
not saying the thought is incorrect no
the question is do you still
go through
what is the right thing to do
there's many examples of this by the way
there's biblical examples
you can have a thought against somebody
that you do not whoa whoa whoa
we need the disclaimer examples we
literally just re-uploaded Charlie
Clerk's clip
what if he wasn't really saying anything
that outrageous
he's saying the truth you've never
thought you say I don't like this person
do you still treat them well
you shut up small faced idiot
yeah that's your fault bro at least own
it don't act like because this is such a
self-owned to put that out there
at least own it like
yeah we took it too far no that like I
don't know if it was that successful but
like hey you know you made your bed now
sleep in it okay well it is so
satisfying to actually see
um that there's consequence for all this
[ __ ] they've been doing here he
literally tweeted this out which is
incredible because it's such a cell
phone if you can't be bothered to at
least try and pick your lawmakers then
people who hate you will someone said
Charlie I don't vote either anymore
because every vote is a vote for a
corrupt political system damn Charlie
cargo like every now and then tweet that
like Balenciaga is owned by Jewish
pedophiles and they get like 700 000
likes and then the one time he's like
hey uh you should probably go out and
vote 1000 likes no one gives a [ __ ] dude
that shit's mid go back to the hits yeah
I agree
um Laura Ingram is pissed you know sucks
man
[ __ ] sucks oh Georgia
she's pissed bro she's ready for a
regime change actually which is kind of
crazy guys uh we appreciate it Bill uh
stay with us all right
um we have more
all right we're not going anymore we
gotta go to Molly Hemingway sorry I have
a whole script in front of me Molly
Hemingway and of course kellyanne Conway
Molly
you and I talked about this about a week
ago we felt this coming
to me it never felt like the Senate
Republicans wanted this guy
in office good he was a trump pick they
didn't like that they probably like him
as a person a Herschel as a person but
there wasn't the intensity on the part
of the Republicans as there was on the
part of the Democrats I felt it you felt
it
but we don't change anything we can be
really funny in office good content it
would be good content he'd like roll up
he'd roll up to the he rolled to the
Senate and be like I'm a cop now I'm
arresting people you know what I mean
how many werewolves in here because I'm
a vampire and apparently y'all can kill
me now and I I didn't know that yeah he
had a lot of fun stuff going on yeah
and people in place apparently at the
RNC that's not perhaps that's not
changing we just keep doing the same
thing over and over again I'm pissed
tonight frankly go ahead yeah it's
really offensive I'm mad for Republican
voters for Republican donors who have
put so much into having some wins and
they just see kind of failure across the
board there aren't people who are
working on early voting or banking
ballots there's no clear messaging I
mean you look at what happened since the
midterm elections where you had a senate
that basically responded to those
disappointing midterm losses by doing
nothing other than sabotaging their own
base
the NCAA tonight
is red meaning you are from here
oh I think yeah bro dude that internet
is Bill's [ __ ] brother
no down time my ass
I think we're back okay
that was just a little bit of an
Internet blip
uh don't worry guys we have 99.9 percent
no downtime guaranteed
well I guess theoretically if it just
dropped for like two seconds
I honestly am so appreciative of the
YouTube streaming platform because it
keeps it one [ __ ] episode together on
Twitch when we used to do the podcast if
it dropped out like that we'd have to
restart the [ __ ] stream bro it was so
annoying
yeah but here is actually the Grizzly
Man 2 this could be you oh that's so
sick yeah that's I want that for myself
I want that for myself so bad
I wish that for myself yeah I think all
the conservatives wish that for you too
but they won't want to chill Vibes
ending
uh I don't know if anything we were
saying was cut off or whatever I think
we were really only gone for about five
I I started interrupting you as soon as
I saw that was down which was right when
it happened so I I don't think we missed
much yeah but anyway they're [ __ ]
Hypocrites right that's that was kind of
the point there so yeah no in between
like in between them saying like we have
no viable midterm strategy like they
literally go back to the same exact fail
strategy of like talking about
children's genitals again you know what
I mean that's like all they want to
[ __ ] talk about well here's a
surprisingly self-aware moment from this
guy uh uh on once again Fox News
I think my take on This Moment of
clarity my take on this is that
I don't think this the the they're
reasonable like counter to inflation was
I don't think that was going to be a
successful uh communication strategy
either but let's go on let's hear you
don't think so they're giving some like
this is what we want to do about
inflation this is what we want to do
about you know
this looming uh what would they session
what was there what was their counter to
inflate nothing no I'm saying what is
the Republican counter to inflation
offering something is better I know but
their their counters are always they
only go one way that that cart goes One
Direction doesn't go in the other that
cart goes in the direction that causes
more inflation like their counter to
inflation cannot be right they it cannot
be more tax cuts for the wealthy which
is what or like cutting Social Security
people would literally be like oh [ __ ]
that I'm not voting for that that's
that's what happened in England and
[ __ ] was not good yeah so that's what
I mean like they kind of are cooked in a
weird way you're right because the the
Republican platform really exists to
promote like the wealth and prosperity
of like less than one percent of the
population yeah deregulation and tax
cuts for the wealthy that's what they
that's that's what they run on and so
when that's your actual goal as a party
you have to lead with the kids genitals
and play culture War stuff because the
actual policies will never win you uh in
any election
but here is a here's Mark Levin the
reason people don't vote is they don't
have a reason to vote what was the
Republican position on inflation what
were they going to do I still don't know
what were they going to the reason
people don't vote is they don't have a
reason to vote what was the Republican
position on inflation what were they
going to do played twice Dan the people
on DPI don't pretend like you don't see
that
I mean what's that do you do you want me
to do it well there's a lot of there's
just a lot of demand for it so just get
a DPI get it out of your system all
right
3200 DPI there you go people Dan's Mouse
has a voice the chat thirsts over my
mouse I accidentally pressed the DPI
button once and
1600 DPI
watch that's so sick they want to [ __ ]
Dan's Mouse yeah 800 DPI what the [ __ ]
yo
they're splooging they're literally
putting sploo yeah why is the mouth so
hot I can't control my right yeah I
can't either I have we found that by
accident Dan won the episode just
changed his DPI randomly and then I
didn't even need to I just accidentally
hit the button and it started yelling at
me yeah and now we haven't been able to
control our goo ever since
let's see um that was weird that was
weird it all turned on sorry to it has
no business being that sexy I just think
now I know Herschel Walker lost but it
is worth lamenting at least some of the
Great Clips oh I love this one I got a
pee while you play this yeah so this
happened
um December 3rd this this was his way of
drumming up support for his runoff
election final the final lead up baby
but um
this is the closer yeah and it does make
me sad that the content will miss but uh
here we go yeah because the Democrats
they already won the Senate because they
you know they got 50 and then the camela
is the tiebreaker so maybe it would have
been fine to have Herschel no because
then it would be a Joe manchin you know
[ __ ] that guy yeah but that's the thing
but now it's still going to be Cinema
you know [ __ ] blocking everything so we
didn't have enough anyways so we might
as well have the comedy I don't know
well here he is regardless and I just
thank you guys
One Last Story
you know y'all have kids everybody have
kids I hope you have kids that they love
to watch all these shows and you have to
sit there and watch them with them and
stuff and sooner or later you get you
like the shows but they don't like them
no more and now you have to watch them
by yourself and you feel like a dirt old
man like I have the rent the neighbor's
kid to go see Jungle Book like a year
ago called my son didn't want to go with
me to see Jungle Book I don't want to
look like a weird guy and it's theater
Watching Jungle Book
he literally has the mentality of like a
four-year-old you ever have kids that
age out of Rugrats but you don't want to
keep it's not even Rugrats like
Teletubbies y'all got age out at
Teletubbies but y'all want to keep
watching Teletubbies I went to see the
teletubbs live action play
by myself
my favorite piano
I was at a Wiggles concert and I was
getting a lot of weird looks so I Ran So
I rented the neighbors kids yeah I
wanted to see The Wiggles alive they
were here but my kids were too old so
you guys think it's weird I mean to rent
your neighbor's kids what the [ __ ] I
thought this was I thought that was the
normal thing I paid my neighbor a
thousand dollars an hour to listen man
Chuck E cheese pizza is is delicious
okay and it's weird everyone gives me
weird looks when I go by myself so I had
to rent the neighbor's kid so we can go
together so it's not weird Okay
sometimes I like to grab a beer and sit
at Chuck E cheese by myself they got the
best pizza kids love Hitler and I'll
just sit there and drink and watch the
kids as they play yeah people think
that's weird so uh that's kind of [ __ ]
up what I do is my Society should allow
that what I'll do is I'll go down to the
orphanage and send the kids out for a
nice day I thought this wasn't coming
communist China really I mean that's
that would not be that behavior would
not be allowed in communist China so
I like Legoland I go by myself
and I sit at the bench and have a churro
and I watch the kids
awesome it's just about awesome stuff
you know okay Legoland is for every age
though Legoland if you don't have kids
is a [ __ ] hell hole trust me bro
excuse me when have you been to Lego I'm
kidding I don't know the kids and I'd
like Legoland because my kids or
Theodore loves it but that there is
nothing for an adult there okay don't
get me started that's a bummer
I love the submarine ride it really you
know speaking of children's television
shows though I did watch Wednesday and
finished it uh did you like do you like
it it was it was really corny
um in many different directions and I
get the appeal of it though like
aesthetically it was cool you know
finally we have an American Hogwarts you
know what I'm saying like sick and tired
of the British taking that for far
that's a Long Point yeah and uh you know
it was all right it was an orange show I
watched the first app and I was like
okay you know it is fun I used to be a
huge fan of Adam's Family oh really they
had like that whole series of movies
were total bangers which was like I've
never watched Doc Brown what's that
what's that actor's name yeah with
Christopher yeah
I've never seen a singular singular uh
Adams Family episode or show I had no
idea I just came in you know I liked it
I like the Adams Family uninitiated I
even I used to watch the old black and
white on Nick at night really I don't
get into it as a kid like I I really
like the the old school Adams Family
that's funny no I never got into that
one weird bro black and white
black and white TV I can't wait was it
from a time when TV shows were black and
white or yeah it was like from the 60s
or something it was like one of the
first TV shows I think it's like old as
[ __ ] brother anyway the the CGI was so
bad and the dialogue was incredibly
corny
but sounds like you hated it fun it was
no no it was like horrible poorly
written poorly conceived cheesy I mean
but it's not for me like I'm not the
Target demographic you know nobody's
like oh man I can't wait to make this
show for a 31 year old Hassan [ __ ] you
know what I mean like I get what the
target demographics for man it is
Wednesday shots are yeah it is Wednesday
by the way Christian Walker's son who
were saying Christian Walker no
Christian Walker who is uh herschel's
son
was lit this was the fam I mean again
this is his son
most of this is a lie considering after
I was born he left my mom in the
hospital to go bang a woman he was
having an affair with after 20 years of
marriage also I was oh wait no that's it
yeah there's more wait he said his son
was an ugly baby with an alien-like head
what the [ __ ] that's kind of messed up
he's like I love the baby because the
baby had bad vibes wait he said that
yeah look Herschel Walker described his
dumb as a brick StreetWise son Christian
as an ugly baby with a long head that
looked like an alien bro that's
Christian Walker's good looking that's
like that's not nice a personal to say I
agree he's a nice looking young lad I
mean certainly not alien-like but that
is your jeans bro so I don't know what
you want exactly
there was one another one from Christian
Walker yeah oh yeah here's the next link
yeah this is the family man remember the
Evangelical vote I was called a backs
chapter back stabber after getting angry
and blowing up from watching my dad live
for 18 months straight but he's not at
back he's not a backstabber for leaving
his two minor children he kept secret to
grow up without a dad as he chased more
Fame and power pathetic raise your kids
I'm with you there on that one buddy
Amen brother
so that's the end of our dock by the way
so you want to talk about something else
no what do you want to do now wow we
actually blew through that okay we got
to end of the dock that's like never
happened whoa this is a this is
what we should say this is our oh no we
have one more episode next week yes and
then we're taking a vague we're off the
air until like the 16th uh until January
uh yeah yeah so next week will be our
final episode of the Year okay we should
play oh you know what I wanted to do
what did you want to do
um how to talk to your
um
Mega family members on Christmas holiday
edition yeah yeah yeah on Christmas
everybody want missed that on
Thanksgiving don't tell them about how
uh your your favorite Jewish podcaster
wants to crucify Jesus Christ don't
mention that yeah they won't like that
apparently which I'm surprised by too
should we have a challenge show this
clip to your concern well actually to be
honest Herschel Walker does kind of have
a point when you look at it a little
closer what the [ __ ] he he actually has
a plan yeah oh messed up cam
sorry too visual to not
don't put that on cam
um I know something we can do because
people have been uh talking about right
as we went live uh Channel five's uh HBO
movie trailer uh finally just came out
oh mama
so ready for that is that on his channel
uh I think so okay it's not on his
channel I think we'll get claimed if we
watch it probably that's that makes no
sense you know why the [ __ ] would
anybody claim a trailer it's an
advertisement the amount of times our
entire four hour podcast has been
claimed because we watched a [ __ ]
trailer
is insane the entire purpose of a
trailer is to get it in front of as many
eyeballs as possible yeah and yet they
want to show my weird podcast for
watching it but I I don't know I mean
it's I feel like it's going to get
claimed they're just like that
I'm trying to think if I don't remember
HBO well let's see watch your screen you
know what I mean yeah they'll probably
block it worldwide I'll be so insane to
do it would be so in this place you
don't want this advertisement to be seen
okay you will pay us to play your
[ __ ] trailer to like 40 000 people
alive
all right here we go we'll see or I
guess he's never said publicly yeah he
wouldn't he wouldn't confirm or deny on
our show
we'll see he had to be bro he was there
on boots on the ground I know the truth
yo he was probably in facade Congress I
know the truth you know the truth you
holding out I will never tell he never
told me
no no I I I knew the truth a long time
ago we detected copyrighted audio and
video on your stream I told you bro
that's crazy it must be the Pavarotti or
whatever so stupid oh yeah the Pavarotti
dude it's copyrighted music bro he
played like you know they probably
bought the rights for some Opera [ __ ]
you know you're right it was I mean it
could have been any of that [ __ ] but
so [ __ ] frustrated HBO what are you
doing
so there you go that's what is [ __ ]
that's this whole system is so [ __ ] up
like here's a two hour long production
tell me about it dude right you just got
booted off the whole internet for two
days
yeah
but I'll be back in a little bit so
there you go just a fun little uh just
lost two hours of work so that was fun
or at least you know we'll just clip it
out if it if it's yellow yeah I still
don't even know what if clipping out
gets the money back for us or any I
literally don't know I don't understand
like they say there's a there when
someone claims your [ __ ] on YouTube they
say if you dispute it it goes to Escrow
and the winner gets it I have not seen
any evidence of money coming back to me
during that period ever like you'd think
there'd be a spike or some explanation
of Revenue somewhere I've never been
able to find yeah without escrow they
mean the YouTube's Pockets yeah we keep
it they just keep it yeah they did a
No-No I mean that would be
that'd be that'd be fraud bro I've been
I've been probing the people I know at
YouTube for an answer to that and they
go huh that's a good question let me
look into it and no one no one has ever
got back
even like our higher up homie could
didn't couldn't get me an answer on that
that's I mean you got to go higher you
got to get to Susan right get Susan on
the phone call her up get her on the
line and be like Susie where is the
money oh people are asking what's up
with Lisa Poole she said I guess the I
guess the pool family couldn't handle
the drama I get it I've been through
that all of it but she did make a video
didn't she about she said that Tim Poole
I didn't watch it wait what did you what
is it she said one of that Tim Paul told
her something about
it's it's complicated family yeah it was
it was too interpersonal it seemed like
not not our business to be to be frank
so I don't know everything she leaked it
she leaked the temple actually has hair
under that beanie
you know what I mean she is the queen of
it all
uh would you guys
no
well what do you think
well you might actually go you know
leave at the right time today yeah for
once yeah we can wrap it up Ethan's like
no let's not leave at the right time I
mean I can hold you here
you want to play uh Jack box or
something no no you can order a pizza oh
or maybe hippos baby hippos sure there's
probably videos of baby hippos that's
already got claimed by HBO for promoting
our friends
documentary
[ __ ] yeah that's the whack
leaving battleships did you beat I've
heard that one well oh God of War oh no
why
um I it's not a good game to stream it's
a girl it's a great game but it's not a
good game to stream so like I don't
really have a lot of time
sure uh and I used the free time that I
had yesterday playing valorant instead
oh are you girthy I I got some decent
girth Game of Thrones or not Game of
Thrones [ __ ] uh God of War is very
girthy as far as games goes well crazy
long penis I guarantee Kratos has got a
fat [ __ ] hog dude why are you
thinking about kratos's Dick you said I
said you said girthy you don't know I
meant like the game is here statues
they're kind of
ancient Greek yes because they have tiny
ones I'm just saying oh maybe his guitar
he did have small penis right that's
true pull out
that'd be a Vibe bro what if having sex
with potatoes again
that'd be still
I'd be like yo let's go tiny penises are
back in baby
yeah people are saying Greeks are
Growers so I mean that's true they are
flaccid in the statues so we don't
actually know what that is the reason
for it you can't grow from that where
you know I mean like there's only so
much I've asked this question because
there was a viral tweet from some like
one of those like weird Hellenist uh
Nazi accounts right and it was like uh
and he was actually tweeting about the
truth the reason why the Greek statues
used to have small penises because they
thought large penises were considered
barbaric yeah and and Primal and and bad
the the Hellenist account was literally
saying like you know that's a bad thing
like he he had the same opinion that the
ancient Greeks did
um small penises versus large yeah yeah
yeah yeah which is the funniest
self-report and then Grimes liked it
right which you know
now we know what Elon is working with
well you guys know I'm pretty barbaric
so you do the math no oh wait I meant
the opposite I mean I'm sophistic I
don't know I have a small I have a tiny
somebody's asking is Ethan going on the
hasanabe broadcast during the break sure
he look at his live voice you see that
sure sure well I said I said next time
you want me on I'm there what
I know I bailed A few times but I'll be
there next time I promise we've asked
we've asked many times folks well not
many what I think it was like maybe
twice at most liar dude I'll come on
I'll come during the break all right
we'll do it I'll be there bro
just be careful because I might get
yours you talking about your pockets or
your stream
both
pecker is mad I usually do both I use I
stream and then after afterwards we do
the podcast usually you're gonna buy me
lunch and be at your house for like 10
hours yeah
always yeah and do your guests get paid
anything [ __ ] no
no babe yeah what's this so okay so so
I'm not okay because I'm not unions what
are you you long mod dude what the [ __ ]
he's like a hundred dollars this is a
non-starter hundred dollars
[Music]
I love him yeah okay so I'm gonna get
lunch I'm not gonna get paid give it to
you well I get breaks no lunch breaks no
to bench breaks no damn
who am I gonna get one of those diet uh
Mountain Dews yeah okay you can get very
different various different flavors that
you know you would you would not be able
to get anywhere oh that's so sick you
have exotic Mountain Dew flavors yeah I
do okay oh it's compelling yeah yeah
and I'll get you some frozen pizza too
what do you what you got what you
working with those exotic I got Mountain
Dew Baja Blast zero no how do you get
that girl I got like
the spark is fantastic pretty good
um I'm still a Diet Mountain Dew uh uh
evangelist though I think it's the best
I do love that [ __ ] I I gotta admit man
yeah a lot of do heads here in the
office a lot of do heads all right well
go have a great stream I know you're
gonna be back uh this year streaming
back so uh yeah God bless first episode
back baby yeah
and um tomorrow we have Brittany Broski
on which is uh I'm so looking forward to
[Applause]